welcome to the second lecture in this
series on how brains work from frontiers
of science online in the first lecture
we talked about the human brain and how
it worked and we pointed out that brain
is are made up of nerve cells or neurons
that are connected together as
functional units neural networks and
today we're going to be talking about
neural networks for vocal communication
we also talked about two principles of
brain function one is what I call the
real estate principle location location
and location and that's the idea that
different tasks that the brain is
engaged in are handled in different
brain regions and that by learning about
different regions of the brain we can
have some idea of how the very complex
behaviors that the brain produces relate
to the neural structures that are
responsible we also talked about the
magnification principle the idea that if
a particular behavior or a particular
function is very important to an animal
that that part of the brain will be
larger than it will and in other species
in which that function is not so
important so in US for example our
visual areas are huge as they are in all
primates and they're a lot smaller in a
bat or maps and today we're going to
talk about areas that are involved in
vocal communication which are also very
large in US and also over-represented in
species for which this is an important
behavior now the underlying assumption
in all of these studies on how the brain
works is the idea that you are your
brain but Francis Crick called the
astonishing hypothesis that you all of
your emotions all of the very complex
aspects that make you what you are are
actually represented in the nervous
system and I pointed out in the last
lecture that this idea is actually
two-way street so the brain both creates
behaviors and is modified by the
consequences of those behaviors and one
of the things that happens is the brain
develops because the brain doesn't know
ahead of time what kind of organism
that's going to end up in is that
experience modifies the brain and
personalizes it so your brain is
different from the brain of everyone
on the planet as a result of your
experience both your learning experience
and your cultural experience but also
the experience that happens inside of
the body the hormones that the brain is
exposed to so today we're going to talk
about that idea and we're going to talk
about a significant aspect of
personalization how brains become male
and female we're going to talk about how
you would discover exactly how that
worked how you take that system apart
and the idea of model organism systems
in which a question of general interests
can be studied rather easily we're going
to talk about a particular model
organism a frog that lives in africa
that sings underwater and sings its
songs in the dark and we're going to
talk about how the male and female
versions of the brain that produces
those different songs is generated and
then finally we're going to talk about
the overarching issue of whether biology
and destiny are inextricably intertwined
and how we might even look at that in an
experimental way
you
so let's start out with the idea of
personalizing your brain so brains are
very complicated they're very
complicated in both sexes and the brain
of the newborn doesn't actually know
that much about the body in which it
resides and there's a consequence of
experiences that that brain has both in
utero and shortly after birth and also
at puberty the brains of males and
females become rather different and one
of the main ideas in this field is the
idea that the experience that's
responsible initially from making the
brains of males and females different
are hormones hormones that are secreted
by the male and female reproductive
organs so here's a diagram of one of
those hormones shown up here and these
are steroid hormones and we're going to
talk about how steroid hormones sculpt
the neural networks that are responsible
for vocal behavior so this is a talk
about the vocal communication of sexual
information of information on
reproductive status on whether
individuals are interested in mating and
we're going to talk about it in a
particular model system and this is the
South African clawed frog Xenopus laevis
now let's talk for a moment about the
Frog because all model organisms are
also organisms with their own
evolutionary history their own
trajectory and their own intrinsic
interest so these guys live in
sub-saharan Africa right below this
cloud blank Bank here and they occupy
this entire region there are lots of
different species of them and as you'll
see in a little while they used to have
a much larger distribution in Africa but
wherever you find standing bodies of
water in Africa you have a good chance
of finding these frogs so this frog the
South African clawed frog you can see
the little claws on the end of its toes
which it uses to reduce food to
manageable proportions has both males
and females as you would expect and you
can see here that the females are a lot
larger than the males a feature that
I've always enjoyed in the species and
that's true in a lot of animals where a
large part of the body mass of the
female is made up of eggs so the word
Xenopus means strange foot and the word
Lavis means slippery and these animals
are so slippery that the males have
developed a special mechanism that helps
them hold on to the females so here's a
view of the underside of the Frog it's
under water and you can see here gloving
the inside of its arms and its fingers
black glove like substance which we call
the natural pad and if you go ahead and
take a look close up using the scanning
electron micrograph at what those
nuptial pads are made up of you see that
they consist of these little epidermal
spines it's a little bit like Teflon so
in this magnification this scale bar is
10 micrometers there are thousand
micrometers in a millimeter so this is
blown up quite substantially you can't
see these very well with your naked eye
now for our purposes one of the good
things about the animal is that it has
distinctive male and female behaviors so
when a male is underwater at night he
sings and he sings very frequently
sometimes for half-hour an hour at a
time producing what we call the male
advertisement call males produce this
call by themselves with other males and
the females are around and it's
advertising their presence to members of
their own species male or female
now females in this species come in two
flavors most of the time they are not
ready to mate and if a male class the
female that's not ready to mate one of
the ways in which she communicates this
is by using a specific behavior called
ticking which sounds like a clock so
ticking is a very effective behavior for
males they let her go
there's no presenta jand hanging on to a
female that doesn't want to mate with
you so one of the nice features of this
system just to begin with is that the
vocal behaviors of the sexes are very
distinctive the other nice feature is
that we can represent the vocal
behaviors very conveniently in a
graphical form so here's a graph which
you will recognize conceptually from
scientific habits of mind our online
text and in the vertical axis is the
frequency in kilohertz thousand cycles
per second so this is the pitch and on
the horizontal axis is time this is one
second and the male called are consists
of trills that are made up of single
clicks where there's a fast part in a
slow part a fast part in than a slow
part whereas female ticking is much
slower they're about six clicks a second
and she goes tick tick tick tick tick so
we have the great convenience in looking
at the way the brain controls behavior
one of the things that we're interested
in in that we can represent the behavior
itself very reliably in this graphical
form
now these animals are extraordinarily
successful evolutionarily when we are
long gone from the planet when there are
only cockroaches these guys will
probably still be around and as you may
remember or will come to in the future
from Peter to medicals lectures we know
that our earth has it seen only five
major extinction events one of which
occurred here at the tertiary Cretaceous
boundary and is believed to have been
triggered by a meteorite hitting the
earth there was an enormous loss of
species diversity during the period that
followed this meteorite but the species
among the species that weren't lost
were the frogs that we work on so you
can trace the origin of these frogs back
to hundred million years a point at
which the continents were all put
together and the ancestor of these frogs
migrated into Africa from Europe Europe
then separated out into a northern
European portion in the southern African
South American and Australian portion
and that was at this point about 150
million years ago that you first began
to see direct ancestors of the animals
that we're looking at and then about 80
million years ago we had the separation
of the great landmass into the South
American and the African continents and
there are ancestors of the species that
went in both directions
some of which are still in Africa today
and some of which is studied by Linda
true at the University of Kansas we can
find in South American up into the
Caribbean and then about 50 million
years ago you can see that what happens
is the African continent starts to drift
northward and dry out but still at that
point these frogs were found in areas
the world that are very dry today such
as Yemen and here are some fossilized
animals from 50 million years ago
that whose skeletons look essentially
identical to animals that we have today
and these have been studied by a Marie
Henry key and
mariya bias and so then today what we
have is species of these frogs
distributed throughout Africa with a
close relative over there in South
America
so why do we study these frogs I mean
they're intrinsically interesting it's
fun to study an animal that's doing such
a good job making it but one of the
reasons we want to study them is that
they are a model organism and a model
organism is an organism because
experimental advantages are so great the
progress in answering specific questions
is accelerated so what we want to know
in these organisms is among other things
what is it that occurs in the brain and
the body that produces such marked
differences in the vocal behavior of
males and females and then at a higher
level we'd like to understand how the
brain and behavior become coordinated in
animals that are engaged in social
communication and you'll recognize here
the fundamental assumption which is that
many of the mechanisms that we see in
one organism be it a fruit fly a mouse
or frog are going to be very strongly
conserved during evolution because
evolution is the great tinkerer it very
seldom throws everything away it starts
over from scratch it builds on what was
there before so if you're looking at an
ancient organism that's working very
well the chances of its having answers
to the questions that you're interested
in in some other organism are very high
so these frogs first came to the
attention of modern day biology that
late 1930s because these were the
animals in which the first pregnancy
test was developed and this test was
popularized by this guy here Sir
Lancelot Hogben an eccentric British
scientist who was a great naturalist and
whenever he moved to a new position and
in this case he was moving from from
North America over to Africa
he'd go turn over the rocks he'd find
the native organisms and he was very
interested in hormones and one of the
things that he discovered was that these
animals if you injected them with urine
from pregnant women the females with lay
eggs and the males would sing and so
that was the first pregnancy test long
before your little strips of paper
turning different colors and that turned
out to be very handy because what it
means is that at any time of year you
can get the animals to sing normally in
the wild they'll only sink
about half a year in the lab you can get
them to sing at any moment and you can
also produce embryos and get them to
grow up they're very handy very Hardy
very sturdy animal incredibly sensitive
to hormones the same hormones in these
frogs as we have in our own bodies I put
this slide up it's actually a drawing
that my daughter made when she was about
10 years old and it brings up a point I
think is very important which is that
even though you're using a model
organism and you're studying questions
of general interest one of the things
you always have to be sensitive to is
the animal itself if you have some kind
of intuition about the animal it often
will help you in your experimental
studies so Danny said after 20 years of
biology dr. Kelley realized that she did
not want to dissect a frog but her
destiny was to be one and you see here
she's put the little glasses on the Frog
she's got the lab coat here's the wig
for the hair of the Frog identifying
with your model organism can also often
be a great help in experimental studies
okay so we want to first of all see if
they have sex specific behaviors which
they do they have the mail advertisement
call which we heard before and female
ticking so they have nice sex specific
behaviors that we can quantify using
sound spectrograms
so how do they produce these songs and
they do it in an interesting way of
course they're singing underwater and
when we talk we talk on expiration air
has to flow out of our lungs in order to
produce sounds but these guys can't
afford to breathe while they're singing
or they drown so what they've done is
taken their voice box their larynx and
modified it so it can make sounds
underwater so here's the voice box it's
a cartilage box that is stiffened by
rods and has muscle on the outside and
part of the sound producing apparatus is
shown here in white these are two discs
and I'll show you the way it works in a
moment but one of the first things that
we saw when we started working on the
animal was that not only were the
behaviors the vocal behaviors of males
and females different but also the vocal
organ itself was very different in the
sexes so the larynx is sexually
dimorphic as what we'd say different in
shape between males and females and you
can see that clearly here so how are
these little individual clicks produced
it's actually pretty simple the muscles
contract tendons pull on the disks and
every time the disks move what happens
is you get a single click sound so here
the disks have moved and produced a
single click sound when they pop apart
so in a male you can have click sounds
as fast as 70 clicks a second and
they're female it's an order of
magnitude lower only about 7 clicks a
second so this difference in the speed
of contraction of the muscles is
actually due to the kinds of muscle
fibers that males and females have males
have mostly fast muscle fibers and
females have mostly slow muscle fibers
so as a model organism we can say first
they have sex specific behaviors and
second the male and female vocal organs
are also different in the sec
so these are good places to start to try
to figure out how the vocal system
becomes sexually differentiated
so what about the brain how does the
brain work and what we did was we
actually took the model organism and
made another model system within the
model organism here's the brain of the
frog it's sitting in its head and it
connects up to its vocal organ and the
cells that go from the brain to the
vocal organ are called motor neurons
they're nerve cells that sit in the
brain and that send a process all the
way down here to the muscle fibers here
their diagram the motor neuron the axon
and what these guys do is when they're
electrically active there's chemical
information passed from the nerve cell
to the muscle fiber the muscle fiber
then becomes electrically active and it
contracts and this connection between
the motor nerve cell and the muscle
fiber which is shown down here that
connection is called the synapse is
called the neuromuscular synapse and
that actually turns out to be a very
good model for the same kinds of
connections that you see in the central
nervous system so in order to figure out
where these cells are in the brain that
are responsible for producing the sounds
what we did was to put small drop of dye
on the axons and they were then this dye
was then carried back by diffusion into
the brain and showed us the neurons that
are responsible for producing the clicks
that produce songs so here you see a
side view of a frog brain this is front
and this is back this is up and this is
down here in this green area are located
the yellow cells that are labeled with
the dye and these are the motor neurons
that go and connect to the muscle fiber
so we can now ask the question of
whether in addition to the fact that
there's a sex difference in the in the
vocal organ itself which you can see
right here here's the male larynx and
the female larynx we can actually also
ask the question of whether the motor
neurons are different in males and in
females so here are male motor neurons
they hear a female motor neurons and I
think even looking at this picture you
can tell that the male motor neurons are
larger than most of the female motor
neurons and it looks like they're more
of
so it turns out they're about twice as
many motor neurons in males and females
so the model system has sex specific
behaviors male and female vocal organs
and male and female brains so what we
want to know next and the reason that
we're using this model system is how
does this work how does this come apart
and this is not an experiment that we
get to do in other organisms that we
dearly love we wouldn't do it in chimps
we wouldn't do it in us but on the
principle that the same principles are
going to apply we can do it on these
guys so these are frogs and like all
frogs they have two major stages of
developments that tadpoles for a while
and then they turn into small frogs and
the small frogs grow up to be bigger
frogs so these guys start out with
fertilization it takes them a couple
months to get to the stage of
metamorphosing from a tadpole into a
small frog and then about a year for a
male to become sexually mature in about
two years for a female to become
sexually mature so what we can do is we
can go and say how do the sex
differences in the motor neurons and in
the muscle fibers develop how do they
come about so what we discover is that
if we look at males and females they
both start out with the same number of
singing motor neurons and then they
start to die they die in both males and
females but they die more rapidly and
there's more death in males and in
females so at the end excuse me in
females and in males so that at the end
of development you end up with a
situation where males have about twice
the number of motor neurons as females
do so differences in the brain are due
to less death in males more death in
females how about the vocal organ how
does that work well if you go back
during tadpole life they start out with
the same number of muscle fibers and
then what happens is males start to add
muscle fibers at a very rapid clip so
that by the time they reach sexual
maturity males have perhaps about seven
times more muscle fibers and females
have and it's quite a marked difference
so male numbers are greater than female
numbers for the muscle fibers not
because fewer cells died but because
more cells are added
so there are two different kinds of
ideas that are going on in males and
females there's the process that leads
to differences in the brain where you
have less death and there's the process
that leads to differences in the vocal
organ where you have more cells formed
okay so we know now when all of these
differences occur we know something
about how but what we don't know is
what's the signal that tells a brain or
a vocal organ to become male like or
female like during development so what
we would say is what's the mechanism
what's the biological mechanism
and we've known for a long time from
studies actually in human beings that
steroid hormones and the ability to
respond to these steroid hormones are
one of the key driving factors in how
brains become male and female and the
sexual differentiation of the brain and
since this information was out there
from mammals and for humans we decided
to go and see whether it was these
hormones that were responsible for
looking at differences in male and
female vocal organs and in their motor
neurons so let me tell you a little bit
about how these steroid hormones work
because they're not like a normal
hormone so let's take testes the testes
make a male sex hormone called
testosterone it's carried in the blood
down to a protein this brown substance
here and then the steroid comes off and
it diffuses in the cell member it
actually dissolves from the cell
membrane it goes inside of the cell it's
picked up by a special protein called
the androgen receptor that whole complex
is carried into the nucleus of the cell
to these guys nestled down together on
the DNA bound to the hormone the
androgen receptor bound to the hormone
and they turn on gene transcription and
one of the reasons that we actually know
this picture pretty well is that there
are human mutants in which the system
doesn't work they have male sex hormone
but their receptors are not capable of
turning on gene expression so these
individuals are often classified as
female at birth they grow up they can't
have kids
and it turns out that they're
genetically male they have testes they
make testosterone but they can't respond
to their own male sex hormone so I think
this is actually a very powerful example
of the important role of steroid
hormones and a lot of the molecular
biology of what we know about the
receptor actually comes from the
specific mutations in individuals with
androgen insensitivity syndrome so what
we did in this study in order to
determine whether the hormones were
involved was we used drugs anti
testosterones that bound to the receptor
but that
could not turn on gene expression and
these drugs are for example used in
prostate cancer which is hormone
sensitive these are pretty powerful they
block the action of endogenous hormones
so what we did was we took the tadpoles
and we grew them up either an anti
hormone or or we didn't interfere with
their development and what you predict
is that if the male sex hormone were
involved we should be able to reduce
male motor neuron numbers to female
levels and you can see that that works
in this slide so here we're looking at
tadpoles that were grown up either
normally so you're looking here at males
in it here at females or in the presence
of anti testosterone the name of the
drug is hydroxy flu tomate so here's the
normal sex difference in the number of
motor neurons and out here we concede
that the number of motor neurons in
males and in females is identical if we
block the action of the sex hormone how
about the muscle fibers the prediction
would be if we gave females male sex
hormone they get more muscle fibers or
if we blocked hormone we should be able
to block muscle fiber addition so here's
an experiment where we gave female male
sex hormone we gave them testosterone
and you can see that the number of their
muscle fibers the error bars again
scientific habits of mind overlap in
male and female so we've been able to
get rid of the normal male female
difference and it turns out that you get
rid of it because fewer cells died in
females that are given the male sex
hormone so in order for the hormone to
work you would expect that both the
brain and the vocal organ would have
receptors for the hormone and you can
actually go and take a look at that once
you clone the gene for the receptor and
what you see here is a cross-section
through the vocal organ and here in this
little itty-bitty piece of tissue right
in here you see a very bright area
lighting up here and here the bright
area in the middle here are the stem
cells that are going to make cartilage
so stem cells in the developing vocal
organ are extremely sensitive to hormone
because they've got lots of the receptor
and out here this bright area is the
developing muscle and muscle stem cells
myoblasts are extremely sensitive to
developing sex hormone and here in the
brain it turns out the expression of the
receptors like a staying for the whole
vocal pathway so here are the singing
motor neurons they were in green on the
previous slide and every single one of
these singing motor neurons expresses
the protein that enables them to respond
to male sex hormone so this is a good
example of how two mechanisms present
preventing cell death and stimulating
the proliferation of muscle and
cartilage stem cells can lead to sex
differences in the brain and then the
vocal organ
now I'd like to actually just go in for
a moment into the Britain and talk about
how the brain produces some of these
vocal patterns and how do you use a
model organism to figure out how the
brain makes songs that are different in
males and females and you'll recognize
here that we're going after the
astonishing hypothesis we want to look
at brain activity that's responsible for
the production of a behavior so one of
the nice things about frogs is that
they're very strongly motivated to sing
so we can put electrodes around the
nerve of the frog as it's singing this
is the nerve that goes to the vocal
organ and we can record the activity
that's coming out from the brain while
the animal is singing and that's enabled
us to do a lot of useful studies and but
one of the things that's so
extraordinary about it is that every
burst of activity in the nerve matches a
sound that's produced by the animal so
here we're looking at electrical
activity in the nerve down here and a
female so here's the nerve activity and
here's the sound that's produced on the
upper trace nerve activity and sound
that's produced so while this female is
ticking each tick is accompanied by a
burst of nerve activity and the pattern
of the nerve activity perfectly matches
the pattern that the sound is produced
in and in a more complicated way we can
do the same recording from the nail
while his advertisement calling and you
can see that each burst of nerve
activity is accompanied by a click and
as the burst of nerve activity gets get
louder the clicks get ladder there's an
exact match between what's coming out of
the brain and the song that the animal
is singing so we used this method and
other methods to go into the brain and
to take a look at the neural networks
that are responsible for the production
of song and we put dyes in various
places we saw how they were connected
we put recording electrodes in to look
at electrical activity and eventually
can't we came up with this scheme here
where you have
vocal motor neurons at the back of the
brain of the hind brain so those are
guys in green here and then you have
clusters of cells that are right here at
the front of the hindbrain so we
identified two sets of circuits that
were implicated in the control of the
song an anterior circuit which includes
this little area here detail in the
anterior hind braid in a posterior or or
more further back circuit the vocal
motor neurons and also the vocal motor
neuron target which is the larynx itself
so we have two parts of the circuit and
what we'd like to know is whether each
part of the de cerca does something
different and at this point we were able
to take advantage of a very strong
genetic control of behavior in Xenopus
and also its incredible advantages as an
experimental model or goat model
organism in terms of how robust it is
and how easy it is to deal with very
early stages of development
so in zenefits each species has its own
song they're about 23 species that we
know of we discovered we think a new one
a couple of weeks ago and each species
has a very distinct song so for example
this is one of the new ones that we just
discovered that was just published and
we may have another one so lay this
you'll remember it goes like this and
then down here here's another Xenopus
species called borealis that has a very
different song so these two songs are
very different and because they're very
different we can actually do an
experiment that would be hard to do in
other animals we can switch the
circuitry between two different species
when the animals are in tadpole stages
and we can create what we call a chimera
so this is an animal that has part of
its brain from one species and another
part of its braid from another species
and you let me just show you how you do
that so you take the embryo when it's
about 24 hours old before there are any
nerve cells whatsoever so there's no
chance that it can feel any pain and
then what you do is you switch the front
parts of the embryo and you put the
borealis front hindbrain and the
structures that are in that part on the
latest back part and vice versa and you
let these guys grow up and you ask the
question of what they sing
when they grow up this is the way they
look they have part of them the front
part comes from borealis it turns out
that the chimeras worked mostly in one
direction so here's two animals with
front parts from borealis the skin is a
little bit darker
this guy mostly has the skin around the
eyes and all the rest of the animal is
latest actually the vocal organ is also
borealis so then we can ask these
animals who want to sing when they're
about a year old what kind of song they
sing now in order to do this experiment
you actually needed control because it's
possible that if they sing a goofy song
it was just because of the surgery that
you use to create the chimera so we also
created chimeras between two different
embryos that were both lavis or both
borealis and the latest chimeras made
songs that sounded like this so they
made a completely normal song and the
borealis made songs that sound like this
so the transplants themselves didn't
seem to affect the ability of the
animals to sing when they grew up so
what about an animal that had the front
part of the hindbrain circuit from
borealis and had the back part of the
hindbrain circuit from Lavis what did it
song sound like this is an experiment
that was done in my lab by Brian Shaw
so in that animal what you hear is a
vocal pattern with an inner click
interval the one that predominates is
identical to the borealis vocal pattern
there are these funky little extra
clicks we don't know where they come
from but the dominant pattern that's
driving the production of the song in
this animal is coming from borealis so
one interpretation of this experiment
it's not the only one but it's a
reasonable one is that the pattern is
created by the anterior Circuit's up
here but the rate is shaped by posterior
circuits and the vocal muscles and these
animals actually had borealis muscles
that can only contract rather slowly so
you have a complicated situation where
you have the rhythm which is generated
by one portion of the circuit and the
ability to contract and relax rapidly
which is generated by the motor neurons
and the hind brain circuit then this is
a kind of taking a part of a neural
circuit that's very hard to do in any
other kind of system
so having taken the system apart we
thought it would be at the end of
apartheid a good idea to go and see
actually how it worked in Africa how did
the animals in Africa use these songs to
communicate with each other so my
colleague Martha Tobias and I packed up
our bags and went off to South Africa to
Cape Town in particular where these
animals come from and we went there to
see what kinds of songs males and
females used when they were singing to
each other in the dark and what Martha
would do here's a picture of her out in
the pond as she go out and she looked
for ponds that had frogs in them by
putting in these funnel traps baited
with bones and come back in the morning
and see whether there are a lot of frogs
and then when we found those frogs we go
out and listen to them at night and we
made a number of very peculiar
discoveries so first thing we discovered
was we could never see them so we never
knew who was calling but unlike the
situation here you know where you go out
at night in the spring and they're ten
zillion frogs calling in Africa we would
only hear one animal calling at a time
it was very mysterious but of course we
didn't know who it was it was dark they
were down leaf litter in order to figure
out what was going on what we ended up
doing was bringing them back to the
swimming pool in the house that Martha
had rented for the summer and taking a
look at what kinds of vocal
communication they made in the swimming
pool and what we ended up doing out of
desperation at the end of the summer was
we put a male in this little portion of
the swimming pool over here with a bone
baited funnel trap and out here in this
portion we put a female and when we did
that we discovered a new calling
behavior that we'd never seen before
we just we discovered that when the
female couldn't find the male she
started to produce a call call which
I'll show you in a second called rapping
it was an incredible stimulant to the
male and I can show you this most easily
and also point out the context in which
these calls occur by showing you this
movie so here we're in the lab and we
got a mail clasping of female and what's
gonna happen is he's going on a ride or
rather she's going tick tick tick tick
tick what happens eventually is that her
ticking suppresses his vocal behavior so
he shuts up and then just for a second
she cause a little bit faster and he
gets all excited again she goes back to
ticking and he shuts up so what we
discovered by going to Africa was not
only a new call that females made not
just ticking which you know before but
also a new social interaction so here's
ticking which is the female call that we
had studied before and here's the call
that we first heard in the female where
she couldn't find a male when she was
about to lay her eggs and we called this
call rapping sounds like machine-gun
fire rapid Geiger counter so these calls
have very different effects on the
male's behavior what happens to a male
that hears ticking is that he shuts up
so that's vocal suppression and rapping
on the other hand functions as a vocal
aphrodisiac and if you play rapping to a
male underwater from an underwater
loudspeaker when these pool loudspeakers
the male will swim over to the
loudspeaker and try to mate with the
loudspeaker he cannot he doesn't nothing
about the evidence of his other senses
the fact that he's touching metal the
fact that there's no female there
nothing about that deters him from the
excitement that's produced by female
calling so I mentioned a minute ago that
when we went out to the ponds we only
often heard one male calling and yet
when we pulled those funnel traps out of
the ponds there were thousands and
thousands of males in a particular pond
so how come only one male calls at a
time so when we bought the animals back
to the lab we began to have some insight
into that and let me just show you how
that works and you'll notice how much
more energetic this interaction between
the males is than the interaction
between the males and the females so
here's a female and here are two males
and we're going to see them calling
we're going to see them ignore the
female and we're going to see them
interacting in a very vigorous vocal
fashion
okay now they face off
one of the nails start to add calling
this guy comes over to its clasp in him
you get so tune in doing so good
umbrella so males also have vocal
suppression and you can take two males
that we're calling for equivalent
lengths of time before you put them
together when you put them together both
of them call les you can see the
vertical axis here this one starts at
3000 this one starts at 1,000 but one of
them shuts up entirely it becomes
vocally subordinate and then if you
remove the dominant male the subordinate
male goes back to calling so both males
and females have these highly specific
vocal interactions and all of their
vocal communication is occurring within
a very specific context so if you look
at the total number of calls that they
produce males produce six calls the
advertisement call the answer call that
really excited one when they hear the
other animal chirping that you heard
chirp chirp chirp chirp
growling murder when their class by an
animal and pleasant calling to the did
that I thought that when they win their
class be another animal and females
produce these two calls ticking get off
my back and wrapping the context of
which is undef to lay my eggs where are
you if you look when males call to each
other they use all six of these calls
they have a very vigorous very rich
social interaction they're using their
songs in a particular social context
when they call two females on the other
hand they only use three of them so
they're actually having a more complex
vocal interaction with females and
surprisingly to me when you put two
females together you don't get any vocal
behavior out of them whatsoever
all they will occasionally fight if
there's if they're both receptive and
there's a male in the tank with them
so these animals have a fantastically
useful system for dealing with life on
your water in the dark nails probably
are struggling with each other facing
off on a female one of them will win and
become vocally dominant probably
displacing the other male and the way we
think that it happens in the ponds is
that they live together in these crowded
murky ponds in South Africa and only one
female becomes sexually receptive at any
time so the males are always ready to go
but there very few females that are
ready to lay their eggs so here's a
female that's sexually receptive here
are all these males ready to go but only
one target for them the singing male
silences all of the other males the
female is attracted to the calling male
she wraps he calls they get together and
the payoff is the production of tadpoles
in the population of the ponds so this I
think is actually an example of the
magnification principle that we talked
about in the first lecture here's an
animal whose entire life is acoustic
whose entire form of social
communication aside from classroom each
other lies in the vocal realm and then
this animal the way that the nervous
system is connected to connect what an
animal hears and what an animal produces
is very highly exaggerated and very
powerful and it makes this kind of a
system very good not only for
discovering what it is that drives
differences in the ability of males and
females to make different vocal patterns
what it is genetically that drives the
different vocal patterns across the
species but also what drives the ability
of two brains to communicate with each
other which is going to be the topic of
the third lecture in this series on the
evolution of language thank you
you